[Music]
hmm
holy smokes
hey there i'm nikki novak and welcome to
rt essentials when it comes to action
movies do you have tunnel vision if so
then this episode is just the ticket
because today we're breaking down some
of the hottest scenes to ever hit the
railroad track yes the railroad track
we're talking trains of all shapes
colors sizes carrying anything from
people to animals to vintage cars toxic
chemicals you name it we don't shame it
if it looks like a train and chugs like
a train choo-choo that it counts as a
train there is one caveat the train must
be in motion locomotion that is but that
is it that's where we draw the line full
steam ahead these are the best train
action sequences on top of a bullet
train fight the wolverine
up first is the on top of a bullet train
fight scene from the wolverine marvel's
six x-men installment the film follows
our favorite retractable clawed
superhero logan aka wolverine who finds
himself in tokyo forced to go on the run
with a powerful industrialist daughter
and push to his physical and emotional
brain logan can't catch a break and this
time he's managed to upset the yakuza
for this scene director james mangold
and his crew had to simulate a train
reaching speeds of almost 200 miles per
hour which was no easy feat
vfx company weda digital founded by
peter jackson filmed the background on a
tokyo freeway building a rig that
consisted of eight red epic cameras to
attach to a van to get as much high
resolution coverage as possible the crew
then drove the van down the freeway at a
constant speed of 60 kilometers this
sounds like the movie's speed which
meant that in post they could speed up
the footage to achieve the fast moving
effect the scene required for the
fighting on the train's roof the actors
were filmed on top of a set piece
hanging on wires and surrounded by a
green screen and of course they needed
lots of fans to simulate the intense
wind but i think they were really just
testing the strength of hugh jackman's
hair gel which is as strong as his nails
in those films ladies and gentlemen as
far as i'm concerned train versus
helicopter mission impossible
how do you take an action sequence on a
train to even greater heights you had
tom cruise and you add a helicopter and
that's exactly what director brian de
palma did in the train versus helicopter
scene from the first mission impossible
film surely you must have known that tom
cruise would find his way onto this list
the guy just loves finding new ways to
put his body on the line for this movie
cruz's character ethan hunt goes on a
covert assignment that takes a
disastrous turn when he becomes the
prime suspect in a murder ethan must
then fight to prove his innocence
literally which culminates in his
death-defying scene aboard the tgv train
to paris
interestingly enough de palma had the
idea for a train sequence before he had
put the film together even a plot for
the film even mapping out how such a
difficult scene would be shot prior to
considering how the scene itself might
fit into the actual movie according to
cruz him and de palma would sit there
with train cars and they didn't have the
story because there was no story but
both agreed it was a very cool idea
[Music]
but how exactly was this seemingly
impossible mission made possible
unsurprisingly tgv rail authorities
wanted no part in this dangerous scheme
but crews managed to get permission to
shoot some of the exterior shots on top
of their fastest train for all the other
shots the crew filmed under a controlled
situation on a sound stage in london
with the actors performing their stunts
on top of life-size trained models
against a blue screen cruz acquired the
only machine in europe of course he did
that could simulate winds of up to 140
miles per hour so that his face would
accurately distort what's a tom cruise
movie without a little facial distortion
at this point we've come to expect it
from him and the rest of the effects
were completed by industrial light and
magic who used a mix of cg miniature
models and projection mapping a lot of
time money and effort went into this one
sequence but you can't put a price on
great action flicks actually yeah you
can the film grossed over 457
million dollars so i'll say it was worth
it
the stanton curve unstoppable
[Music]
unstoppable is the perfect title for a
film about an unmanned locomotive that
roars out of control and features the
stanton curve sequence where a
csx8888 train narrowly clears the sharp
turn of a viaduct and avoids derailment
unlike mission impossible there was no
need for director tony scott and
screenwriter mark baumbach to craft a
plot that incorporates a train scene
because not only is this entire film
mostly set on a train but it's also
based on a true story you might have
heard of the real life crazy aids
incident or a train of 47 cars 22 of
which were fully loaded ran uncontrolled
at speeds of over 50 miles per hour for
almost two hours oh yeah a couple of
those cars also contained thousands of
gallons of molten phenol a severely
toxic chemical that could unleash
imaginable harm if the train were to
crash in a populated area i bet cruz was
mad he didn't think of that one so his
time cruz there's always time
so
in unstoppable denzel washington plays
frank barnes a veteran railroad engineer
who risked his life to stop the train
assisted by a young conductor named will
coulson played by chris pine barnes and
coulson anticipate the stanton curve
implementing the independent air brake
and reducing speed just enough to keep
the train from flying off the track
scott insisted on using real locomotives
borrowing from the canadian pacific
railway wheeling and lake erie railway
and the southwest pennsylvania railroad
for the stanton curve sequence where the
train tilts on two wheels some cg was
required and the surrounding fuel tanks
were added with vfx to raise the stakes
scott's dedication to authenticity
earned him critical praise with roger
ebert calling the film superb and the
new york times writing that scott
creates an unexpectedly rich world of
chugging rushing trains slicing across
equally beautiful industrial and natural
landscapes sadly this would be the last
film scott would direct before his death
in 2012 but it proved to be a profound
bookend to an unstoppable career
blackout fight snow piercer
precisely 74 of you shall die
my friend you suffer from the misplaced
optimism of the doomed
this is going to be good the blackout
fight scene from bong joon ho's sci-fi
film snow piercer is nothing short of
terrifying actually the film's entire
premise is terrifying imagine an ice age
caused by global warming then that
forces humanity's last survivors to
board a world spanning super train with
the elites ruthlessly controlling the
lower class passengers who are forced to
the tail section of the train if you're
at all claustrophobic i'd avoid watching
this one during the blackout fight
sequence the train known as snow piercer
enters a tunnel causing complete
darkness at the worst possible time
right smack in the middle of an all-out
rebellion the tail mob progresses
forward after realizing that the guards
are carrying weapons with no ammunition
but when things go dark only the guards
are equipped with night vision so that
he can slaughtering the blinded rebels
with melee weapons yeah the apocalypse
wasn't enough let's squeeze all of
humanity into one narrow vehicle then
turn the lights off and give the angry
guards axes and night vision goggles
bong juno really knows how to stress out
his audience please refer to parasite
for further evidence of that
most of snow piercer was shot in a set
at barandov studios in prague with the
crew building a 100 meter train replica
a giant gyroscopic gimbal was used to
give a three-dimensional feel to the
train and juno wanted audiences to have
a sense that whichever way the shot is
moving that's where the characters are
going and he really pulled it off the
film is a bumpy ride you constantly feel
like you're in motion and part of the
action i kinda liked it not gonna lie
though snow piercer was a massive
technical achievement for june ho and
his crew one of the hardest parts of
filming was trying to hide chris evans
muscles evan's character curtis everett
was a revolutionary type supposedly on
the verge of starvation which didn't
exactly line up with his captain america
physique shall we say but thankfully the
nifty costume department worked their
magic and kept evan's superhero bod in
check god i always have to keep my bond
and check it's so tough i so feel for
him
bond excavates a train skyfall
[Music]
[Music]
skyfall was the 23rd film in the james
bond series the third to star daniel
craig in the leading role of double07
and as far as i know the first to
feature a two-ton caterpillar digger on
top of a locomotive i'm talking about
the scene where bonn excavates a train
while fighting with a mercenary named
patrice who has stolen a hard drive
containing precious information about
undercover agents the scene has it all
motorcycles cars trains
shootouts fist fights m yelling at money
penny bond taking time to adjust his
cuffs after being shot in the chest
because you know he's got his priorities
straight and of course a bond operating
an excavator to rip open and jump into
one of the trained carriages in pursuit
of patrice all without breaking a sweat
[Music]
director sam mendes and his crew had
their work cut out for them but instead
of relying heavily on cgi or massive
models like many other modern actioners
do mendes went with a more traditional
approach production shot on location in
adana turkey and captured this train
sequence on a real speeding train with
craig and co-star ola ripass attached to
safety wires chugging along at 40 miles
per hour the two actors perform most of
their own stunts which is impressive
considering the intense physicality
required for this sequence okay the shot
where bond dives backwards off a 300
foot viaduct and crashes into the water
was actually craig's stunt double andy
lister who was attached to a safety line
but that's only because craig didn't
want to get his suit wet again
priorities priorities he needed a
cocktail at that point curving bullets
on a train wanted
[Applause]
next up is the curving bullets on a
train scene from the 2008 thriller
wanted directed by teamer beck mombadak
the film finds wesley gibson an office
worker who follows in his murdered
father's footsteps by joining a secret
society of assassins gibson is recruited
by fox played by angelina jolie and
along with the help of the society's
leader sloan played by morgan freeman
gibson is able to tap into his
previously dormant powers gibson has
been conditioned to kill cross a rogue
assassin who has left the secret society
and after the two have an unexpected
shootout gibson traces a bullet and
manages to eventually track cross down
the two face off once again on a
speeding train and this is when we see
some serious curving bullet action the
car is filled with pedestrians so gibson
and cross have to find clever ways to
shoot around the innocent passengers so
they fire their weapons sidearm putting
a spin on the bullets akin to a slice in
tennis i call that an ace
[Music]
the bullets collide and cancel each
other out which happens with many shots
in this scene by the way the odds of two
bullets colliding in midair even one
time are extremely low but we will
definitely suspend disbelief it is a
movie after all and a fun one while
we're busy computing the physics of
curving and colliding bullets fox drives
her car into the train causing a
derailment as the train crosses a narrow
bridge to avoid spoilers i won't reveal
what happens next between gibson and
cross but it's something like the luke
and darth vader reveal too much
information anyone anyone i am your
father for this sequence several
full-size l-train cars were built on a
green screen stage with a petalino car
constructed on a hydraulic gimbal that
could rotate and tilt to simulate the
train flipping also most of the actors
performed their own stunts in this film
but we'd expect nothing less from jolie
who famously performs an estimated 99
of her own stunts just one percent
behind tom cruise
the train heist fast five
we're being rocked whatever happens
don't stop the train
any action-packed episode is not
complete without at least one fast and
furious scene this time it's the train
heist from fast five directed by justin
lin and released in 2011. vin diesel
jordana brewster and the late paul
walker star in their iconic roles as
street racing criminals this time
they're on the run from authorities and
find themselves in rio de janeiro where
they attempt to steal three cars from a
train i don't know if you've ever tried
to steal a car from a moving train but i
can assure you is very difficult
especially when that train is filled
with dea agents and armed henchmen but
hey if anybody can do it it's finn
thanks to the franchise's proven success
fast five was given a hefty budget of
125 million dollars but just this one
train sequence ended up costing over 25
million to produce which put into
perspective is more than what it costs
to make films like a quiet place and
parasite and roughly what it cost to
make the grand budapest hotel and la la
land
yes none of these movies feature vin
diesel propelling a corvette out of a
speeding train just seconds before it
crashes and explodes but still that is a
lot of cheese for one scene though this
sequence did rely on cgi much of it was
filmed practically production actually
purchased part of a working railroad and
the necessary trains to boot at least 12
replicas of this chevy corvette roadster
were ordered from an ohio-based builder
and five of those were stunt cars three
of which were shot from an air cannon
out of the train into the lake it took
three weeks to capture this scene a
shooting in rice california which sits
at the southern tip of the mojave desert
if those cars are still there could i
excavate them now because i love me a
corvette it was an ambitious undertaking
for lynn and his crew but all worthwhile
because fass ended up grossing over
666 million dollars at the box office
runaway train spider-man 2.
[Music]
one of the most revered superhero films
to date sam raimi's spider-man 2
features the runaway train scene where
spider-man faces off with supervillain
doctor octopus on the top of an elevated
subway car filled with civilians doc ock
grows increasingly annoyed with spidey's
relentless pursuit and decides to take
out the conductor increase the train
speed and cut the brakes before uttering
you have a dream to catch then ejecting
himself from the situation really doc
couldn't she be more like that
human-loving octopus and my octopus
teacher love him spider-man's mask is
damaged from a small explosion and he's
forced to take it off revealing peter
parker
this is important because spidey had
been wrongfully deemed a masked menace
by the city and now he was exposed just
a kid faced with the extraordinary task
of stopping this train and its
passengers from crashing
you have a train to catch using all of
his strength and powers he manages to
latch his webs to the surrounding
buildings and halts the train just feet
before it plummets into the river below
the enormous effort drains parker he
falls unconscious only to be gently
carried away by the train's passengers
who express their gratitude for his
heroic actions it's one of the most
beautiful scenes in the film only to be
ruined when doc ock crashes back onto
the train terrorizing everyone yet again
much of the scene was shot with cgi
which you can kind of tell but as any
native new yorker will be eager to point
out nothing is as fake as having
above-ground subways running through
midtown manhattan just doesn't exist
circus train chase indiana jones and the
last crusade
come on
anybody out there suffer from
ophidiophobia i.e an overwhelming fear
of snakes if so you should probably
avoid watching the circus train chase
from the last crusade the third
installment in the indiana jones
franchise this scene was set in 1912 and
featured river phoenix as a 13 year old
indiana who steals a golden crucifix
from a group of grave robbers and gets
chased on horseback across the
countryside the angry mob catches up to
indy in their cars and india is forced
to leap from his horse onto a moving
circus train the men follow him on board
and indie jumps from car to car
eventually coming face to face with an
anaconda and then landing in a vat
containing hundreds of smaller snakes my
worst nightmare ever spielberg shot this
sequence in colorado on the kumbras and
toltec scenic railroad and used the
denver and rio grande 484 steam engine
which was repainted as the fictional
pueblo and shama railroad
[Music]
[Music]
the car chase and horse transfer shots
were filmed just south of antonio or an
actual road runs alongside the railroad
so the crew had to use dirt and brush to
cover up said road as for the train's
interior spielberg's shot on set at
universal studios hollywood oh nothing
like an easy sound stage part of what
makes this prologue so compelling is
phoenix's performance perfectly
encapsulating indiana his look his charm
his propensity for mischief ford himself
even recommended phoenix for the part
which was quite a hat tip or fedora tip
i should say
batman versus raz al ghul train fight
batman begins
pressure's moving along the mains
blowing all the pipes and if that
pressure reaches us the water supply
right across the whole city is gonna
flow
and last but certainly not least is the
batman versus raz al ghul train fight
from christopher nolan's batman begins
in the film a young bruce wayne travels
to the far east and trains with the
league of shadows led by raz al ghul
everything is going as planned bruce is
learning ninjutsu he's practicing his
fears bonding with his mentor so what's
the catch well bruce discovers that the
league of shadows believes that killing
is necessary and that gotham city is
beyond saving and must be destroyed i
mean the name league of shadows is
pretty shady so maybe you should have
seen it coming just saying regardless
bruce burns down the league's temple and
escapes supposedly killing raz al ghul
in the process so when batman and raz
finally face off again during the film's
climax on the train the tension is extra
high
familia don't you have anything new how
about this
nolan has always preferred using
traditional methods and shooting things
in camera as much as possible but for
the monorail sequence he needed to
combine miniature models cgi and
live-action footage to achieve the
desired effect for the interiors the
crew built two full-size train carriages
and shot on a large 360 green screen
stage bale and neeson had properly
rehearsed for their fight which allowed
nolan to rapidly run the scene over and
over setting up the camera in various
positions for full coverage nolan's work
was met with critical praise and batman
begins is often cited as one of the most
influential films of the 2000s and that
concludes our list of the best trade
action sequences of course we couldn't
include every scene that fits the bill
far far too many trains too little time
but fear not there's plenty of episodes
of rt essentials coming your way so i'm
sure we'll get there eventually choo
choo thanks for tuning in i'm nikki
novak and one more thing about trains it
doesn't matter where they're going what
matters is deciding to get on board
[Applause]
[Music]